the Trump Russia scandal continues to
grow as disgrace disgusting degrading
depraved and delusional former Trump
national security adviser Michael Flynn
has been indicted and has pleaded guilty
making him the fourth person charged as
part of Robert Robert molars
investigation the second to have pleaded
guilty already along with george
papadapolis and of course we also had
the indictments of paul mana for and his
business partner rick gates some weeks
ago both of them pleaded not guilty but
let's talk about Michael Flynn today and
the implications Flynn has been charged
with and pleaded guilty to lying to the
FBI about conversations with the Russian
ambassador Sergei Kiss lyac last
December and this is the charge this is
the key thing okay this is the charge
that Flynn agreed to plead guilty to as
part of a plea agreement right which
includes some degree of as yet unknown
cooperation between Michael Flynn and
prosecutor Robert Muller Flynn can now
tell Moeller whatever he knows and
that's really the biggest part of this
and the future of this investigation may
hinge on what Flynn knows and what Flynn
tells Robert Muller now Trump's reaction
has been hilarious unhinged outrageous
panic really almost unintelligible panic
taking to Twitter throughout the entire
weekend starting with I had to fire
general Flynn because he lied to the
vice president and the FBI he has pled
guilty to those lies it is a shame
because his actions during the
transition were lawful there was nothing
to hide
also the President of the United States
tweeting so general Flynn lies to the
FBI and his life is destroyed while
crooked Hillary Clinton on that now
famous FBI holiday interrogation with no
swearing in and no recording lies many
times and nothing happens to her rigged
system or just a double standard
committed right wing trumpet reaction to
the charges against Michael Flynn
these charges are so small that they're
almost meaningless and they have nothing
to do with Donald Trump whatsoever well
there's kind of two ways to look at that
talking point right that these are just
minor charges against Michael Flynn
number one is the way that some Trump
fists want you to look at it which is
these charges are really small they're
going nowhere and it means absolutely
nothing about the presidency of Donald
Trump I tend not to agree with that
the idea that Flynn was only charged
with this and thus it's not a big deal
is wrong Flynn was only charged with
this one count because he is cooperating
and he's being charged early remember
this is only the fourth indictment and
it's been going on I think our first
indictment was like seven eight weeks
ago he's being charged early because
Robert Moeller thinks that he can go way
higher than Flynn he can use Flynn to go
up and get indictments against even
bigger players do not be tricked a
national security adviser being charged
is a big deal no matter what the charges
are don't fall for the right-wing lie
that it's only a minor charge we're only
ten months into this administration and
we have four indictments including
someone who worked at the White House
the idea Pat that oh nothing to see here
because the charges against multiple
Trump officials and campaign staffers
are not big charges that is laughable
yeah I mean I think I would just
disagree with one minor point that you
said there which is that you can go way
higher than Flynn how much higher than
Flynn can you go maybe Jared Kushner
maybe five now Trump that's about it
Flynn was the national security adviser
after all but you can go higher that's
the key and and I think that that's the
really it's a question for Robert volar
right and that is an interesting thing
that Pat is pointing out which is
national security adviser works at the
White House and this particular NSA
worked at the White House while Donald
Trump was president the the fact that
it's coming so early tells us so much
about how high it may go but of course
Flynn was a former Obama administration
official yeah yeah yeah he was why did
Obama agree to hire Flynn in the first
place and that's actually I don't know
if I would call it an irony I don't know
what I would call it but President
Obama told Trump don't hire Flint don't
hire Flint and we don't know if it's
because Trump doesn't respect Obama's
opinion or because he wanted to do the
exact opposite of anything that
President Obama said Trump could have at
least avoided part of this it just
listened to President Obama and that is
very very interesting this also by the
way sheds a ton of light onto Trump's
multiple repeated attempts to shut this
thing down asking Comey to shut it down
asking Republicans to try to shut it
down we'll get to that later in the show
even though Trump keeps telling us he's
not worried he's not acting like someone
who isn't worried and I jokingly tweeted
something like Mike Flynn can't place
the guy must have been a nobody don't
remember who that was a Donald Trump has
a new lawyer dealing with the Russia
probe and the guy's name is and this is
for real Ty Cobb Ty Cobb is the name of
the new lawyer that's representing
Donald Trump with regards to this
investigation
he actually said listen Michael Flynn
served briefly in the administration and
after all it's only one count that he
pleaded guilty to some left wingers by
the way are also playing this down I
don't even have time for them Pat at
this point I can't deal with the left
wingers who still say there's no Russia
story didn't Trump specifically ask
James Comey in the Oval Office to let
the Michael Flynn investigation go
yeah because Clinton was a good guy or
something yeah it's this is this is not
the behavior of someone who thinks this
is this is going to lead to nothing and
the highlights are four indictments in
eight weeks Papadopoulos in early
October manna four and gates October
30th Watergate took years the National
Security Adviser is cooperating and
Trump is scared that is the top line and
we're gonna continue following it the
video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership